very good afternoon to you the
government's emergency planning
committee cobra has been meeting this
afternoon to discuss national services
ability to cope with the heatwave the uk
is heading for record temperatures
earlier next week early next week excuse
me prompting a warning from the met
office that people's lives could be at
risk the cabinet office minister kit
malthouse chaired today's cobra meeting
and gave this update a short time ago
so our main concern is to be sensitize
everybody to the fact that there are
particularly vulnerable groups who will
need us all to look out for them uh so
critically the elderly very often living
alone and very small infants who are
particularly prone uh to be affected by
this kind of heat and so we're asking
people that while they should take
precautions themselves stay in the shade
drink lots of water stay hydrated
um that in particular they look out for
those two groups and do the neighborly
thing for example knock on an elderly
neighbor's door make sure they're okay
they've got access to water you've got a
tiny baby make sure it's kept cool
possibly in in a colder bath or you know
chilled uh in some way uh just being
sensible about the plan is what we're
most concerned about
london uh
nag is at the cabinet office and the
very fact that there was a cobra uh
meeting ashna highlights the scale of
this hot weather that's coming
you're right to mention it cobra
meetings are preserved for emergency
occasions and this we know has been
deemed a national emergency by the met
office hence the reason why this cobra
meeting was indeed held this was the
second cobra meeting to have been held
after the uk's health security agency
declared this heat that we're
experiencing at the moment and likely to
experience over the next couple of days
heading into monday
as extreme that's meaning that they've
made it a national emergency declaring
that it is to be deemed a level four uh
state of emergency which means what does
that mean well it means it's going to be
uh impacting health it's going to be
impacting travel it could lead to power
cuts and i'll come on to the travel a
little bit later on but we know that
cobra meeting did as i mentioned just
wrap up in the last uh half an hour or
so it was led by cabinet office minister
kit malthouse we know the prime minister
boris johnson was not present but the
fact that this meeting was indeed held
today on a saturday usually government
business wouldn't necessarily happen on
a weekend but it was like it was to
discuss a number of potential measures
that they might have to introduce if
this weather does really take a toll not
only on the national health service but
also on vulnerable members of the
community people in varying
various places across the country this
warning stretches across much of england
from here in london all the way up to
manchester and then further up north
just touching the vale of york we know
when it comes to travel there is likely
to be quite major disruption is what
network rail are preparing us for
they're saying that passengers should
expect that there will be delays on some
services that's because the trains will
have to run at such a reduced speed
because of the heat of those tracks and
they're going to have to manage services
in line with that hot weather that we're
likely to see here in london the london
underground is also going to be impacted
passengers told here to prepare for
severe disruption and if you're living
in the capital it's not only the travel
you're going to have to be keeping an
eye on but also pollution levels we know
that there is a incredibly very high
pollution alert that's been issued for
monday here in the capital which
obviously is going to impact those with
respiratory conditions but also those
without and that's crucial to this red
weather warning and health warning in
that it can it has been deemed so severe
that it will affect the health of those
who are deemed to be healthy but it is
as kit malthouse we heard from there
so important they say that people out
and about do
touch on and go and see vulnerable
members of the community check on people
to check they're able to keep cool all
the while keeping an eye on the amount
of
water that's being used by people but
the overarching issue is is here
the met office say the uk is used to
playing in the sun but this they say is
not whether to be played with and that
we should really keep care take care